what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it looks like Marvel Studios is
about to make some huge changes to how
they release content in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe we have reports today
that suggest that Disney knows that the
Disney Plus shows aren't exactly
performing well right now and they are
now done with the six episode 200
million dollar budget we'll dive more
into this news in this video but the two
biggest most important questions to ask
about this big change is one what does
it mean for the MCU and two will it
actually work will getting rid of Disney
plus projects from Marvel Studios or at
least cutting back on Disney plus
projects will that make the MCU better
both Bob Iger of Disney and Kevin feige
the president of Marvel Studios have
acknowledged that things haven't exactly
been performing well on the Disney plus
side of Marvel Studios however things
haven't exactly gone well for movies as
well except for Guardians of the Galaxy
vol 3 recently so we'll dive into
everything you need to know about what
is happening in this video and if you're
new be sure to subscribe to stay up to
date on all the latest MCU news and if
you subscribe and leave a comment on our
videos you're automatically entered in
our giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items the winner gets to pick
one item and we pick a winner at the end
of each month so today's report is
coming from The Insider account can we
get some toast and this is what they
stated in a tweet last night MCU content
bloat is real feige and Iger know this
say goodbye to the six episode 200
million budget Disney Plus shows now
right away this doesn't exactly mean
that Marvel Studios is going to just be
getting rid of doing all sorts of Disney
plus projects because they do special
presentations as well as the full-length
Disney Plus shows and even if they do
decide to completely get rid of the
Disney Plus shows I don't think that's
going to actually happen until after
phase six we've already got too much
lined up too many projects in the works
to just completely bail on Disney plus
however is Marvel Studio is going to
scale back yes we already actually knew
this and both Kevin feige and Bob Iger
have separately said that they are going
to be cutting back on content and this
of course is so they can try to increase
the quality of the content that they do
put out in fact last week Bob Iger
acknowledged that Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 performed well but
acknowledged that the other movies
haven't he said and I quote the
performance of some of our recent films
is definitely disappointing and we don't
take that lightly we are focused on
improving the quality and performance of
the films coming up end quote so Marvel
Studios and Disney of course are already
in the process of taking steps to make
their content better and one thing that
Marvel Studios might be considering
doing is maybe putting Disney plus
content on hold phase one through three
was pretty fantastic no all films
weren't 10 out of 10 but we had a ton of
really great movies and the Marvel
Cinematic Universe itself just kind of
felt well well a little bit more
connected than it does now and they did
that without any Disney Plus shows so of
course Marvel Studios would consider
Disney Plus shows as the reason that
there's a little bit of content bloat
right now and perhaps the reason why the
movies aren't performing as well too
because we do know that there are super
fans out there like myself and like
probably most of you who are watching
this video who will probably watch
anything that Marvel Studios puts out
however there is a big majority of
people out there who do kind of feel
fatigued there's a lot to watch and a
lot you have to keep up with and that
can get tiring so it is very possible
that Marvel is considering kind of
scrapping Disney Plus shows now I don't
think they'll actually do this however I
do think they're going to cut back in a
really big way and I actually think that
the projects that we do get are going to
be longer six episodes between 30
minutes to an hour isn't enough Nine
episodes is probably alright but
Daredevil is gonna give us 18 episodes
and when you have 18 episodes It's okay
if some episodes are 30 minutes long
because you still have enough time to
tell a good story and that brings us
into the question will this actually
work if Marvel Studios cuts out the
Disney plus content and just reverts
back to movies well this actually fix
the quality of their films Guardians of
the Galaxy vol 3 was a great movie but
before that the previous four films fans
didn't like that much Ant-Man and the
WASP want to Mania black panther wakanda
forever Thor love and thunder and Doctor
Strange and the Multiverse of Madness so
why weren't these films received that
well was it due to the MCU Disney plus
content that was also out there or and I
think this is the real question we need
to ask is it just due to bad quality and
bad writing yes there are a lot of
complaints about the recent Disney Plus
shows and the recent movies and yes the
ratings have been going down but is that
due to fatigue or bad storytelling
because let's go back to phase four one
Division and Loki were massive successes
and a large majority of the fandom both
the people who talk about this and watch
videos about this every day like
ourselves and the general population
they consider those two the best Marvel
Disney Plus shows there have been and a
lot of people say that the quality
declined after those two shows now we've
had great ones like Moon Knight and
others but the approval rating keeps
going down but what people tend to talk
about online is simply the story people
aren't going oh no we have another
Disney plus Marvel show that we have to
watch to keep up that's really not what
people are saying and in fact most
people get really excited for a show but
then Midway into it or at the end of it
they'll give up on it because they don't
like the direction that it went secret
invasion is the perfect example it
started off really strong and a lot of
people were really hooked but by the end
and especially at the finale fans
clocked out then you see people online
talking about how they're not gonna
watch anymore Marvel Disney Plus shows
for a bit but that is mostly due to them
being disappointed in the quality and
the direction of the storytelling so
getting rid of Disney Plus shows from
Marvel Studios or cutting back on them
still won't work if the storytelling is
bad however cutting back on them or
eliminating them altogether will
increase the quality of what we do get
in theory at least let's say Marvel
Studios decides to severely slim back on
Disney plus content because again I
don't think they're going to get rid of
it altogether but let's say they release
one maybe two Disney Plus shows a year
and three films a year that's a pretty
drastic cutback from releasing four
films a year and four five six Disney
Plus shows a year this will allow the
people at Marvel Studios to put in the
time and the care into the few projects
that they now have and in theory the
quality for everything should go up the
storytelling the CGI the filming with
more time and Care pretty much
everything should improve but again if
the story is still bad the shows and the
movies are going to continue to be bad
so I don't really think that Disney plus
projects are the issue I do agree that
there are probably too many Disney plus
projects because they are spreading
people too thin who work on these
projects they're rushed they have
limited time to make something good and
we've heard about the complaints from
VFX people at Marvel Studios saying that
they really don't have enough time they
are pressured and they don't get paid
enough to work kind of overtime for all
the work that they need to do on these
projects to complete them so the workers
are exhausted but if you cut back on how
many shows you produce a year they won't
be and they could put more care into
what they're doing not that they don't
care right now but they are stretched
pretty thin so what does this mean for
Marvel Studios well like I mentioned I
don't think they're gonna stop doing
Disney Plus shows until after phase six
and once phase six hits they could make
a decision to stop doing Disney plus
projects because it is kind of going to
be a little bit of a soft reboot no The
Avengers aren't going away and it will
be in the same MCU but we're gonna start
off with a Fantastic Four and then the
X-Men two completely different groups
with their own stories to tell so it's
almost like we're getting a phase one
and of course when Marvel Studio started
the first three phases we didn't have
Disney Plus projects so they might
decide to kind of start the same way put
all of your effort and all of your time
into making the X-Men into making good
Fantastic Four spin-offs and sequels so
we could see them cut Disney plus
projects but I don't think that's going
to be forever if they do it I think it's
going to be temporary and eventually
they'll bring them back but like I
mentioned I think they're probably just
going to scale back a bit making one
maybe two Disney Plus shows a year this
still gives them a lot of time and they
can still devote a lot of effort and
Care into making the projects that they
want to make now there's also the
possibility of seeing this a little bit
online that they could increase the
budget for these Disney Plus shows and I
don't think that's gonna happen because
secret Invasion had a 200 million dollar
budget and the finale was rated the
worst out of any Disney Plus show so
despite its massive budget it's still
underperformed so money clearly isn't
the problem we know Marvel Studios and
Disney has money and we know they could
throw more money into any series that
they want to and have a huge cast like
Sam Jackson Amelia Clark Ben mendelsohn
Kobe Smulders etc etc and it can still
fail despite having a huge cast and a
huge budget it has to be about the
quality of the content they put out and
the storytelling but no doubt Marvel is
about to make some pretty big changes so
brace yourself for either a cut
completely of Disney plus projects or
them scaling back in a huge way so these
are our thoughts about this please let
us know what you think about this in the
comments down below if Marvel Studios
decides to no longer make Disney plus
projects do you think this will help fix
the MCU as far as quality is concerned
or do you think that it's a different
problem like storytelling please let us
know all your thoughts about this in the
comments down below and again don't
forget to subscribe so you can stay up
to date on all things relating to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and so you can
enter our giveaway you can always follow
us on Instagram and Twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf